hello everyone like I've mentioned in my
previous video we're gonna check out at
least one more game from round seven of
the 2018 bill chess festival but we're
actually we're gonna show both of them
as we've already seen one as wigglers
very nice victory against gear goddess
but now we have a magnus carlsen versus
maxime beaugeois grab in the first half
of the tournament you've seen they've
reached a pretty equal end game but then
Carson was able to push the drawn
position into into a full point here
what happened it's also very interesting
we'll just have to check it out and see
and as yesterday was the rest today
we're gonna check out some of the photos
and also we have a couple of photos
before the tournament so here you have a
photo of course and taking a selfie with
with a fan well rather a fan is taking a
selfie with Magnus Carlsen and in my
opinion this is not the correct way to
take a selfie and you should really hold
it the smartphone horizontally not
vertically as you know while this might
look nice on your Instagram story
anywhere else it will not you know the
format will just not be okay so you know
just to take you know hold your
smartphone horizontally and then you
know you can always shift your
smartphone 90 degrees but you know not a
lot of people shift their PC monitors
the 90 degrees so yeah just thought I'd
share that with you guys so here we have
a photo of Carson you know putting his
and the MBL's name in the sheet before
the game so if any of you are interested
in Carson Sandra and handwriting this is
this is it basically then we have a game
before the start of the game this is the
handshake here we have a photo of course
and pondering on the position it's a
very very difficult game so you know
it's it's a realistic photo and here my
favorite of this of this video here is a
nice very nice close-up of of Maxine
where she'll like Rob a very serious
photo with the mustache and everything
and you can see his eyes are somewhat
bloody but this photo was taken before
the game even started so it's not too
due to the complexity of the position
but rather there was a there was a boat
trip yesterday so I guess they had a
they had a very nice party which if
that's the case makes this game
that more impressive so without further
ado let's check out the game we already
seen one night off in Fiddler Jurgis so
here we're gonna see another one
Carson opens with E for and we all know
what Maxine replies to e4s he is of a
well-known Sicilian expert he goes c5
Knight to f3 d6 we already said that we
will have a night off on the board so
there it is a 6 and the Carlson plays f3
here we have e5 kicking the knife from
away from a central square and I'd be
three and Bishop to e6 Bishop to e3 h5 a
very nice move not allowing white to
expand in the future with h4 in g4 Queen
to d2 and the now comes Knight B to d7
Knights the d5 we have Bishop captures
on d5 pawn captures on d5 and now g6
Bishop to e2 Bishop to g7 preparing to
Castle kingside and here it's alright to
castle both King side and Queen side
depends on what kind of a game are you
interested in playing as a yesterday was
the rest day you know they were on uh
they were on a boat Carson was not at
least I don't think he was so maybe he
wasn't feeling all that well or
something you know most people would
Castle queenside here as they already
have f3 played maybe then you will play
h4 g4 and start pushing it's very
unlikely the Blackwell Castle queenside
in any variation but Carson prefers
castles King side so ok we have castles
King side a5 now preparing to push a 4
which would pretty much force the
Knights to go back as the Knights really
doesn't have all that many good squares
here so Carson pushes a for himself
another allowing Maxime to push it
we have castles and the now comes at
Bishop to b5
Queen to c7 and now c4 we have a b6 and
now comes H three nights the c5 Knight
captures beep me captures on c5 and now
across and said that he was very happy
with his position here he really
controls the light squares on the Queen
side completely and he said that he did
like his position but he mostly enjoyed
it because he had this rook to a3 to b3
plane but without that he's
that white it doesn't really have much
here so okay rook to a3 going on with
his plan at night to h7 preparing f5
rook to b3 now and now comes f5
preparing f4 and E for even Bishop to c6
Carson is now threatening to bring the
rook over to b7 and here there are 2
ways to prevent this you can go rook b8
or rook to a7 it's very interesting both
ideas are very interesting Maxime says
that he didn't enjoy rook to a7 because
of this Queen to e1 move Queen do you
want to move a very nice idea simply
freeing the D 2 square for the bishop
and then after Bishop goes to D 2 the
Queen Bishop battery will be eyeing the
a5 phone and after the rook comes to be
5 it will be very hard to defend the a 5
point so instead of rook to a 7 Maxime
decided after Bishop to c6 to go rook a
to b 8 I simply counter the rook on b3
crossing plate
rook to b5 he was very happy about this
now you can't really capture the rook
after he captures you know you just
created a white a free pass born that's
not how you play chess
select rook to b5 we'll have F for
attacking call since Bishop cross in
plays Bishop to f2 and the now comes a 4
and now comes the very nice moment in
the game here mvl said that he thought
that Carson could never allow this point
to ever reach III he thought that after
pawn captures he will play Bishop to b5
creates a nice blockade here and then he
will be able to set up his pieces and
pawns the way he prefers on the King
side and maybe even you know consider
pushing here but he missed cousins next
move cousin played Queen to c2 and
Carlson said that he saw this move a
long long time ago and that he kind of
knew or that he was hoping that maxim
would miss this and it did happen so a
very nice very nice idea by Carlsen
the idea here is if you now push III
which Maxine thought was impossible
because how could you ever allow this
you know to create such a powerful test
pawn it's because Bishop to e1 is now
the the you know the the move that gives
white a lot of advantage visit because
now your g6 pawn is hanging and your a
five point is hanging and you cannot
defend the both of them so Maxime had
refrain from playing this and he played
Queen to e7 now preparing to push III
now but now Carlson captures with the
Queen Queen captures on e4 would have
Queen captures pawn captures and now
comes Knight to g5 rook to e1 defending
d4 pawn and now Knight to f7 here cross
in place rook to be one he protects the
B to pawn while getting ready to capture
here Knight goes to g5 Maxime brings the
knight back attacks d4 pawn as he
doesn't think cousin can actually
capture the a5 one but cousin does this
he plays rook captures on a5 and now
Maxine plays rook to b3 cross encounters
it rook to b5 and here
Carson said that while he was
calculating Brooke captures an a5 and
everything that he thought that okay you
can play rook to be three because now
you'll have to exchange but here Maxime
played looked to be a rook to d3 and the
Carson said in an interview after the
game that he he forgot the d3 Square
even existed he didn't even take this
move into consideration but you know the
rook is perfectly fine there it's a
light square black a white can't kick it
away from there okay rook to e1 guarding
d4 pawn and now comes f3 and now white
is in a whole lot of trouble here
of course you cannot capture Knight
captures deals check wins the exchange
in the game so after F 3 H 4 was played
a kicking away amok seems night night to
f7 and now what do you play here it's
interesting that the the move that seems
perfectly logical g3 would actually cost
you the game in the long run here it
seems like okay you created a weak f3
pawn now you'll play rook e3 next move
but it doesn't work because after night
comes to e5
you are you know you although you do
have a dark square bishop you will be
extremely weak on the dark squares for
example rook to F 1 group 2 d2 now after
a white place any move you black will
play Knight
before and now there is a very very
little you can do here if you move the
bishop then point to f2 is coming if you
don't move the bishop any move you play
let's say Bishop to d7 would lose you
the game the bottom line is white would
have to sacrifice the exchange here and
then he would pretty much be playing a
losing endgame or if you don't if you
play something like there should be
seven attack the Knights then Knight
captures rook actors and now you see how
black how white is very weak on the dark
squares of course there is no way to
defend here and you lose the game so
after Knights to f7 constant of course
did not play g3 he played a5 he simply
started pushing his passport which is
what you should do with passed pawns
which you know I will say this because a
lot of you mentioned this in the
comments when I when I say a passed pawn
I mean a passed pawn
das sed a passed pawn I don't know I do
not say a fast phone so although a
passed pawn is very fast you know it's
not a fast point it's a passed pawn so I
hope that's settled now Knight to e5 a6
cousin continues pushing his passed pawn
rook to d2 and the now comes a seven and
here Maxine plays F captures on g2
allowing this knife to now deliver check
on f3 even allowing Carson to
temporarily bring his Queen into the
game so cousin plays it a queen Knight
to f3 check forcing the King to capture
on g2 King captors and now Knight
captures any anyone with Czech Bishop
cannot recapture because the bishop is
pinned King to f1 and now rook captures
an f2 King captures anyone and only now
rook captures on a8 king captures an F -
and now rook to f8 check and as you can
see after all the 7 done here it seems
Crossing is up upon but he is not gonna
be able to keep this pawn if he tries to
defend at the age 4 point because Maxime
wants to bring his rook over to f4 if
you play something like King g3 you will
get a bishop to g3 Bishop to e5 check
forcing your king to move back for
example King g2 and then the rook will
win this pawn if you are persistent and
try to defend this pawn for example
working to h3 then after rook 2f
you will lose the game as there is no
defense against a rock to h2 checkmate
so you know there is an active King but
there is also a too active King which is
never good
so after rook to f8 check King to e2 was
played rook to F 4 of course maxime
wants to grab Carlson's extra pawn
before C capture some before and now
cross and doesn't even bother
recapturing but rather he pushes c5 and
this is a very nice example of active
play now you're giving black so many
options what to do you can capture on h4
you can capture you can capture on c5
you can capture on e4 with check there
are so many options here let's say you
play D captures on c5 then you get d6
and now the bishop is guarding d4 pawn
you can no longer capture with the rook
after we play Bishop to f6 guarding the
queening squared the d8 white will
simply bring his King over you will
capture this pawn and then white will
play King c4 and capture all of these
pawns and you know it will be a close
game most likely a drawn game but it's
only y'see that will be able we'll be
able to push for something more here on
the other hand after this c5 move you
could play something like rook captures
on e4 with check then you get King to
have three attacking the rook rook
captures here and then rook to b8 check
King f7 and only now captures on d6
Bishop to have six a must play move you
would have to protect the Queen in
square but now Bishop to eh check King
moves and now d7 the rook is already
guarding the queening square but it
doesn't matter
b 3 is coming here and after you bring
the Queen into the game captures
captures now rook to be 4 is coming and
it seems like it's actually now black
that we'll be able to Queen but luckily
White has a rook to d6 and now it's
forced to draw after b2 Bishop captures
and g6 guarding the queening square you
will win whites light square bishop and
now it's a 2 rooks and two pawns a
completely drawn endgame so although
it's it is a drawn magazine still goes
Bishop to e5 allowing Carson to capture
so we have pawn captures on d6 and now
Bishop captures on d6 King to d3 King
f7 rook to b6 threatening to to move
this bishop with a discovery and the
wind this dark square bishop but Bishop
to c5 by Maxine a rook to see if rook to
b5 Mikaelson Bishop to d6 ripped a b6
Bishop to c5 and rode back to b5 and it
was in this position unmoved 49 that the
players agreed to a draw so a very nice
game definitely it was a Crossin who was
struggling to save his position later he
he did achieve a sort of a promising
position but there was never anything
actually there but in like in the first
half of the tournament of course he
would try to you know push for something
if there was something to put for but
here there wasn't so a very nice game
especially after a rest day and after a
nice boat party you know by both of them
really really enjoyable chess
so yeah that's Coulson vs. MBL from
round seven of the 2018 bill chess
festival I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you're enjoying the series so far I
would like to thank Bill hammer for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another game from round round 7 of the
2018 bill chess festival Indian we're
gonna check out the standings thank you
all and I'll see you soon